- So we were talking about your kids.
So what do they think of
your TikTok dance moves?
- So here's the thing.
Basically, they think I'm the worst,
and I'm just like, can I just
remind you that I'm Honey.
I'm Honey.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
Did you see the movie?
I mean, ladies?
- [Jessica] They're just
like mom, but when you do it.
- [Kelly] Look at him, look at him!
But look at the little one.
- [Jessica] They're like
mom, but when you do it,
it just feels like you're trying too hard.
- Look at that, look at that!
No, it doesn't.
They're jealous, jealous of your moves.
- I was like, just let me live.
Just let me live
- And have a good time.
- I think it it's so
important, 'cause my daughter,
she thinks she's like, you are so silly.
Even the movie ended last
night, and the ending credits,
and we have a thing in our house
when the ending song comes on,
no matter if it's sad or
happy, we have a dance party,
and we don't know why.
We just get up and do it, and last night,
they were kind of tired, and
I just was flailing around.
And I think it's awesome for your kids
to see you kinda like that,
'cause then I feel like
especially this day and age,
kids, I don't know if they're online,
but they get so trapped
into that mentality
of it's not cool, or I can't be myself,
or people won't accept
me, or won't get likes.
It's a hard thing.
I think it's good you're
doing stuff like that.
- I think so, and I also
think it's good for them
to allow me to be silly, allow me to be,
to giggle and allow me to be a person,
and then I feel like
they'll have more compassion
in life for everyone
else, but also not for me.
- For y'all's relationship.
- And for our relationship,
which I think is good.
- I have to say they had to
think this was pretty cool
because you got Zach Efron
into one of your TikTok videos,
so I wanna show this video real quick.
This is amazing.
So they had to have
thought this was amazing,
that you got him in.
Did they think you were cool?
- They were like, wait, what?
They were like, is he coming over?
How did you get him to do this?
Does he think you're a stalker?
They were so confused
about how it happened,
and I was like, I did a
job with him in Dubai,
and by the way, he did a video with me.
- [Kelly] Yeah, exactly.
- What are we even talking about?
- It's so funny beause
my kids will be like,
you know this person?
I'm like, yeah, but they know me too.
I'm like, wait, what?
- But our kids don't know why.
- [Kelly] Our kids don't care.
- They have no idea.